श्रीमद् राजचंद्र पत्रांक 528 भाग पहला।
तारीख 8-11-2000 श्री देवचंद्र भाई।
णमो अरिहंताणं णमो सिद्धाणं णमो आयरियाणं णमो उवज्झायाणं
णमो लोए सव्व साहूणं नमः समयसाराय
स्वानुभूत्या चकासते । चित्स्वभावाय भावाय
सर्वभावान्तरच्छिदे मंगलं भगवान वीरो,
मंगलं गौतमो गणी। मंगलं कुन्दकुन्दार्यो,
जैनधर्मोऽस्तु मंगलम्॥ सर्वमङ्गलमाङ्गल्यं
सर्वकल्याणकारकम। प्रधानं सर्वधर्माणां
जैनं जयति शासनम॥ ॐकारबिन्दुसंयुक्तं
नित्यं ध्यायन्ति योगिनः।
कामदं मोक्षदं चैव ॐकाराय नमो नमः राजचंद्र वचनामृत पत्र number 528
five twelve स्वप्ने जेने संसार
सुखनी ईच्छा रही नथी अने संपूर्ण
निसारभूत. और संपूर्ण
निस्वार्थभूत जिसे
संसार का स्वरूप
भासियो
है। एवा ज्ञानी पुरुष। कैसे ज्ञानी पुरुष? जिसको सपना भी नहीं
आता है कि बाहर से
सुख मिलेगा। संसार में से कुछ मिलेगा।
सपने में भी नहीं, सपना भी नहीं आता है। और जिसे संपूर्ण निस्वार्थभूत
जिसे संसार का स्वरूप भासियो है।
अनुकूलता है तो भी उनको सार नहीं लगता है। नहीं तो अनुकूल... लगता है। नहीं तो
अनुकूल time में तो लगता है कि नहीं संसार में कोई जेने ऐसा है। ये भी एक मजा है।
प्रतिकूलता तो अच्छी नहीं लगे लेकिन अनुकूलता अच्छी लगती है।
लेकिन ज्ञानी पुरुष को तो अनुकूलता में भी सार भासित नहीं होता है।
ये अनुकूलता टिकने वाली नहीं है कब छू हो जाएगी मालूम नहीं। ऐसा स्वरूप है संसार का।
संपूर्ण निसार भूत।
जेने संसार नु
स्वरूप। बासिं। स्वरूप. वास्युं छे. एवा ज्ञानी पुरुष पण. वारंवार आत्मा
अवस्था संभाळी संभाळीने उदय होय
ते पारब नैवेद्य छे. एसे ज्ञानी
पुरुष को भी संसार में बहोत तकलीफ होती
है. तीरने में. बहु समुद्र में डूबे है जीसको सहारो
नहीं मिले वो तो बिचारे. तीरंगे कैसे? लेकिन इनको सहारो मिला है.
लेकिन अभी तो का चोथा गुण स्थान. लेकिन अभी तो कहाँ चौथा गुणस्थान और कहाँ
परमात्मा की दशा। चौदहवाँ चौदहवें गुणस्थान।
वो भी पार कर देना तो तो जाकर सिद्ध भगवान बनेंगे।
तो बहुत साधना विकट है। परमात्मा बनने की साधना बहुत विकट है उनको
भी बहुत तकलीफ होती है तैरने में किनारे में आने में उनको भी तकलीफ होती है।
ऐसे ज्ञानी पुरुष। वो भी
बार-बार अपनी आत्मा की दशा को संभाल-संभाल करके।
जानकारी में जागरूकता में रहते-रहते। जानकारी में जागरूकता में
रहते रहते जैसा उदय आता है
ऐसे अपने नसीब को भेजते हैं
सुख में दुख में सब उनको भी और शोक होता है
अंदर में चिंताएं होती हैं ये सब तकलीफ भोगते हैं
ये सजा मिली है भूतकाल में किए हुए कर्मों की सजा है
कभी रास्ता नहीं सूझता है ऐसा भी बनता है कैसे tackle करना situation tackle कैसे करना
बहुत तकलीफ होती है। ऐसे ज्ञानी पुरुष भी बार-बार
आत्मा की अवस्था संभाल-संभाल कर उदय होता है। ऐसे प्रारब्ध को वेधते हैं।
जैसा कर्म का उदय आता है ऐसा हुआ है। स्वीकार कर लेते हैं।
सुख को, दुख को, सबको स्वीकार कर लेते हैं।
लेकिन आत्मा अवस्था ने विषय प्रमाद थवा देता नाथे। साधना जिसको जल्दी-जल्दी करनी है।
बाहर में सुख आओ चाहे दुख आओ लेकिन। बार में सुख आओ चाहे
दुख आओ लेकिन। अपनी जागृति के अंदर थोड़ा भी प्रमाद नहीं करते
हैं। ये तो किसकी बात है जिसको
संसार में थोड़ा भी सुख भाषित नहीं होता है।
अनुकूलता भी प्रतिकूलता के समान। तकलीफदाई है
मोहित नहीं होते हैं अनुकूलता में भी। इतने सावधान हैं श्रद्धा इतनी मजबूत होने वाले
ज्ञानी की ये बात है।
वो भी निरंतर पुरुषार्थ करते हैं प्रमाद नहीं करते हैं।
अपनी आत्मा को। अपनी आत्मा की अवस्था को संभालते हैं। कैसे संभालते हैं?
आत्मा की अवस्था को कैसे संभालना? उपयोग पलटाना।
नहीं उपयोग पलटाने का तो हो ही नहीं सकता है। फिर कैसे संभालेंगे? द्रव्य दृष्टि से।
अपना जो मूल स्वभाव है उसको देखते ही,
उसका आधार लेते ही, परिणति में अपने आप change आ जाता है।
परिणति अपने आप सुधर जाती है।
इस प्रकार से वो बार-बार प्रमाद किए
बिना अपने स्वभाव को बार-बार बार-बार ल...
अपने स्वभाव को बार-बार बार-बार लक्ष्य में लेकर के
सहज में ध्यान आदि क्रिया में लग जाते हैं। लग जाते हैं नहीं हो जाता है
सहज सहज में क्योंकि दूसरा कोई रास्ता ही नहीं है। संसार सागर तैरने
का और कोई रास्ता नहीं है पूजा भक्ति
व्रत तप नियम ये कोई रास्ता नहीं है। स्वभाव का लक्ष्य रहे
जानने वाला निरंतर दृष्टि में रहे वो संसार सागर तैरने का है
उपाय है। तो ज्ञानी पुरुष
जिसकी श्रद्धा तो पक्की हो
गई है अब फंसने वाले नहीं हैं संसार के प्रसंगों में क्योंकि
सारभूत नहीं लगते हैं कोई भी प्रसंग।
नहीं फंसने वाले हैं तो भी वो
बैठ नहीं गए हैं कि चलो अभी हाथ पे हाथ रखकर अब तो safe हो गए ना।
पहले तो कोई सहारा ना था अब तो नैया मिल गई ना तैरने के लिए
तो बस अगर बाहर हो जाएंगे कैसे भी करके।
हो जाएंगे वो तो निश्चित है।
लेकिन फिर भी वो प्रमाद नहीं करते
हैं। प्रमाद ना हो। प्रमादना अवकाश योगे अगर वो प्रमाद
करेंगे तो. ज्ञानीने पण
अंशे व्यामोह थवानो संभव. कहेलो
छे ज्ञानी भी मोहित हो सकता
है संपूर्ण नहीं अंशे. अंशे उनको भी भ्रांति हो सकती
है. प्रमादना अवकाश योगे अगर स्वरूप को नहीं संभलेगा स्वभाव का लक्ष
नहीं करेगा बार. एसे ज्ञानी को भी अंश में व्यामोह. जो
भी अंश में व्यामोह
भ्रांति होने का संभव। जे संसार से कहो छे।
ये संसार का स्वरूप ऐसा है कि वो भी मोहित कर लेता है ज्ञानी को
पूर्ण स्वरूप से नहीं करता है क्यों?
आत्मा का अनुभव एक बार हो चुका है।
लेकिन जागृति में नहीं रहेंगे
तो वो भी आकर्षित करते हैं और जितना आकर्षित करते हैं उतना ही
कसाय तीव्र होता है।
कसाय में उठापटक बहुत होती है। तीव्रता गुस्सा तीव्र हो जाता है।
हो जाता है अच्छा नहीं लगता है द्वेष बुद्धि आ जाती है
अनुकूल परिस्थिति में राग हो
जाता है क्या होगा
तो प्रमाद ना
अवकाश योग है मतलब अगर स्वभाव का लक्ष्य नहीं करेंगे तो
उसमें काफिल रहेंगे तो ऐसा पुरुषार्थ नहीं होगा तो
ज्ञानी को भी आंशिक रूप से मोह होने का संभव है।
मोह बढ़ने का भी संभव है। मोह मतलब कौन सा मोह बढ़ेगा अब?
दर्शन मोह वाली भ्रांति तो खत्म हो गई। चारित्र्य मोह बढ़ता है।
और स्थिति ऐसी बनती है कि अज्ञानी की स्थिति
अच्छी होती है और ज्ञानी की स्थिति खराब दिखती
है। इतना सत्संग करता है, इतनी आराधना करता है लेकिन फिर भी
कोई परिणाम में change नहीं आता है। क्यों? प्रमाद।
स्वभाव को नहीं संभालता है।
बार-बार बार-बार बार-बार स्वभाव का लक्ष्य करना चाहिए वो
नहीं करता है। इसमें प्रमाद करता है।
हे, इसमे प्रमाद करता हे. हे तो वो से मुक्ति तो होने ही वाली हे लेकिन इतना
प्रमाद भी उसको नहीं करना हे
क्योकी संसार बहोत विचित्र हे. संसार के
जो संग प्रसंग हे वो इतने जीव को कल्याण
में इतने अंतराय डालते हे के अगर उसमे पुरुषार्थ नहीं रहा तो
problem आ सकता हे. ते संसारमां आवा संसारमां जे ज्ञानीने पण मोहित करे छे.
ते संसारमां साधारण जीवे रहीने.
तेनो व्यवसाय लौकिक. तेनो व्यवसाय लौकिक
भावे करीने आत्महित ईच्छवुं ए नहीं बनवा जेवुं
ज कार्य छे. जीस संसार में कदम कदम पर ज्ञानी
को भी बहोत संभाळ संभाळ करके बहोत जागृति में रहे करके बहोत पुरुषार्थ
करके बचना होता है. एसे इस संसार के अंदर जीसको आत्मज्ञान
नहीं हुआ है एसे साधारण
जीव को. संसार भी संभाळना है कुटुंब परिवार शरीर आदि ए भी संभाळना है. शरीर
आदि ये भी संभालना है।
और आत्म कल्याण भी करना है। Possible नहीं है ये बात। एक साथ दो कार्य नहीं
कर सकते। या संसार या आत्मा। किसी को एक को तो छोड़ना ही पड़ेगा।
अभी क्या है कि संसार में तो रंगे गया है तो आत्महित को छोड़ा हुआ है इसने।
पूरा change करना पड़ता है। सपने में भी संसार नहीं चाहिए।
उठे जैसा है मैं सहन कर लूंगा,
adjust कर लूंगा लेकिन आत्मा किसी भी हालत में चाहिए चाहिए
चाहिए। आत्मा किसी भी हालत में चाहिए
चाहिए चाहिए ऐसा अगर निश्चय दृढ़ नहीं हुआ
तो उसको संसार में भी रस है तो फिर वो कार्य नहीं हो सकता है one one side होना चाहिए
कोई भी एक side पकड़ना है किसको साधारण जीव
नहीं तो उसकी बस की बात नहीं है क्योंकि ज्ञानी
के भी बस की बात नहीं है बहुत मुसीबत से वो आगे बढ़ रहे हैं
तो मुमुक्षु जीव को तो बस की बात है ही नहीं उसको तो बहुत संभालना है
ऐसे संसार में ऐसे
विचित्र। एसे संसार में एसे विचित्र. चारो ओर से बाधारूप.
संसार में साधारण जीव
को तो. संसार की प्रवृत्ति भी
लौकिक भाव से करना. वा आत्महित की चाहना
रखना. नहीं बनने जेसा कार्य हो. क्युं एसा क्युं? केमके
लौकिक भाव आडे आत्मानी निवृत्ति ज्यां नथी आवती. त्यां हित विचारणा बीजी
रीते थवी संभवती नथी. त्यां उलटता है जीव. उलझता है जीव। तो क्या होता है?
निवृत्ति नहीं मिलती है। एक के बाद एक, एक के बाद एक कार्य आते रहते हैं और उसमें
ये तो करना ही पड़ेगा, ये तो फर्ज है हमारी। इतना नहीं करेंगे तो कौन करेगा?
करे बिना तो चलेगा नहीं, लोग क्या कहेंगे, आजू-बाजू वाले क्या कहेंगे? ये तो
चाहिए ही चाहिए, ऐसा करके
जो लौकिक भाव में प्रवृत्ति करता है,
तो निवृत्ति नहीं मिलती है साधना करने के लिए।
निवृत्ति मिले तो अपने हित के बारे में सोचें,
निवृत्ति नहीं मिलती है तो हित के बारे में... निवृत्ति नहीं मिलती है तो
हित के बारे में कैसे सोचेगा? पहले जो planning करना पड़ता है।
ये संसार में हर कार्य planning करके करता है ना, कोई भी कार्य हो।
ये Mumbai जाना है तो planning से।
मेरे ticket available है कि नहीं, कौन सी date fix करना। कब जाना है, कब आना है।
कब अनुकूलता है। ये सब decision पहले करता है ना, बाद में कदम उठाता है।
इसी प्रकार से इसमें भी आत्मदर्शन उसी को
होता है जिसको पहले सबसे... किसी को होता है जिसको पहले सबसे उसके पहले
आत्मदर्शन होने के पहले planning होता है mind के अंदर
सहज रूप से। जब आत्मकल्याण करना है तो planning करना है तो उसमें बाधा रूप जो जो है
वो सब छोड़ना पड़ता है। Mumbai भी जाना है और यहाँ का काम भी संभालना है।
तो फिर नहीं हो सकता है फिर आपको यहीं रहना है।
यहाँ का काम किसी को हवाले कर सकते हो
या 3 4 दिन 5 दिन 8 दिन के लिए pending कर सकते हो
तो ही आप जा सकते हो। तो दोनों काम साथ में कैसे करें?
ऐसे ही यहाँ पर भी एक ही काम करना है, लक्ष्य एक ही, मुझे
अभी आत्मकल्याण के सिवा कुछ नहीं करना
है। बाकी सब जो होगा उदे अनुसार।
तो लौकिक भाव आडे आत्मा ने निवृत्ति ज नथी आवती, लौकिक विचारना में पड़ता है,
ओ संग पोसंग बढ़ जाता है, नहीं करना चाहिए ओ संग बढ़ाता है।
मुमुक्षु का संग कम और लौकिक जनों का संग ज्यादा जिसको आत्मा की बात भी पसंद नहीं है।
तो क्या हो गया रुचिपूर्वक असत्संग में गया। सत्संग में गया।
रुचिपूर्वक तो ये लौकिक भाव आ गया,
लौकिक भाव के आड़े फिर इसको निवृत्ति नहीं मिलती और बेकार के
चर्चा विचारणा में समय जाता है। सत्संग भी नहीं होता है इसके अंदर।
तो
जीव को आत्महित की विचारणा करने के लिए planning करने
के लिए समय भी नहीं मिलता है। एक निवृत्ति तो बीजानु परिणाम थमु
थमु संभव है सर, एक एक का stop होगा
तब दूसरा चालू होगा। जब तक संसार की प्रवृत्ति चालू है तब तक
आत्महित की प्रवृत्ति... की प्रवृत्ति
चालू है तब तक आत्महित की प्रवृत्ति नहीं है, विचारणा भी नहीं है।
और आत्महित की प्रवृत्ति है,
तो संसार की प्रवृत्ति नहीं है। प्रवृत्ति नहीं है मतलब बंद हो जाता है ऐसा नहीं है।
ये हमारे को भूसा हो गया।
आत्मा के पीछे लग जाएंगे, ध्यान उधर लगा लेंगे तो संसार की जैसे
सारी प्रवृत्ति बंद हो जाएगी। खाने का ही मन नहीं रहेगा, पीने
का ही मन नहीं रहेगा, नींद भी नहीं आएगी ऐसा।
या दुकान भी नहीं जाएंगे, घर-बार का काम भी नहीं होगा, ये हमारे को mind में भूसा है।
प्रवृत्ति रहेगी, प्रवृत्ति करने का जो
भाव है वो निकल जाएंगे। करने का जो भाव है वो निकल जाएंगे क्यों क्यों ऐसा होगा
क्योंकि अभी हम खाना बनाने का भाव करते हैं
और फिर खाना बनाते हैं प्रवृत्ति में हमको
ऐसा भूसा भूसा गया है कि हम ऐसा planning किया
खाना बनाने का भाव आया
रोटी बनाने का विचार आया और फिर हमने ये
सब planning करा तो रोटी बनी अगर हम विचार नहीं करते तो रोटी नहीं बनती थी
विचार किया इसलिए रोटी बनी है
बिल्कुल गलत बात है विचार अलग है। बिल्कुल गलत बात है। विचार अलग है,
वो आत्मा ने किया है।
और रोटी बनना नहीं बनना वो
lot, चकला, बेलन आदि जड़ पदार्थों का कार्य है।
असल में तो lot का कार्य है। असल में, निमित्त में दूसरी बहुत सी चीजें हैं।
इसमें एकाध निमित्त ये भी ले लो कि इसका भाव। क्या? निमित्त में। कर्ता में तो रोटी
भाई ने बनाई नहीं। ऐसे दुकान के भी कोई काम हमने
नहीं किया है। हमने सोचा इसलिए कार्य हुआ, बिल्कुल गलत बात।
तो फिर... सोचा इसलिए कार्य
हुआ बिल्कुल गलत बात तो फिर हर वक्त ऐसा होना चाहिए देखो अपने भावों का अवलोकन करो
भावों का अवलोकन करके देखो
कि 1 घंटे में हमने 1000 बातें सोची हैं 1000 बार विचार आए अच्छे बुरे
कितना कार्य हुआ अगर भाव के अनुसार हमारे भाव के अनुसार दुनिया चलती है
तो जितने जितने हमारे भाव आते हैं सब के सब हमारा इस प्रकार से कार्य होना चाहिए
जैसे मन में किसी को भाव आया कि इसको थप्पड़ मार देना है बहुत हैरान करता है मेरे को
मार सका। मार सका? Action आया ऐसा?
नहीं आया। मन में 10 बार 15 बार भाव कर लो। लेकिन action आना हुआ क्या?
ये क्या बताता है? Percentage देख लो चलो।
इन भावों का percentage देख लो कि
कितने भाव हमने किए उसमें से कितने सफल हुए। तो भी आपको लगेगा।
कि भावों से दुनिया नहीं चलती है। भाव जीव करता है अज्ञानता के कारण
और कार्य... के कारण और कार्य जैसा
जड़ का परिणमन होने वाला है
ऐसा होता है। ये अवलोकन में सबसे पहले ये सीखा शिक्षा लेना है। सबसे पहले
ये सीखना है अवलोकन के अंदर।
कि हम बेकार का कर्म बांध लेते हैं कार्य तो होता नहीं कर्म फुकट के बांध लेते हैं।
भई जिस कार्य के लिए गया
travel की ₹500 ₹1000 खर्च कर डाला और वहां जिसको मिलने गए वही नहीं मिला। क्या हुआ?
समय और शक्ति और बेकार का दंड हो गया कि नहीं हो गया?
वैसा ही हमारी जिंदगी ऐसी गुजर रही है।
दिन भर में हजारों प्रकार के अच्छे बुरे भाव कर लेते हैं।
कर्म का पोटले तो हम बांधते हैं और वो भोगना भी हमको ही है आप इस। लेकिन कार्य
कितना होता है?
तो आप आप खुद महसूस करोगे कि 95% 99% भी आपकी इच्छा से नहीं होते हैं कार्य।
फिर बेकार के भाव क्यों करें?
फिर संसार हमारी इच्छाओं के... ये संसार हमारी इच्छाओं के अधीन नहीं
है। 3 साल का बच्चा
भी हमारी बात नहीं मानता। वो
अपने हिसाब से रहता है अपनी मर्जी अनुसार।
अगर उसको अनुकूल परिस्थिति नहीं है तो वो रोता है चिल्लाता है।
उसको जब तक अपने अनुकूल परिस्थिति में रखेंगे तब तक अपना से
राजी है नहीं तो राजी नहीं है वो।
सब सब जीव स्वतंत्र है सबको
अपना अपना अपना अपना जहाँ जहाँ सुख भाषित होता है वहाँ वहाँ रहने
में आदी हो गए हैं। उसमें
अगर घरवाले भी अगर तकलीफ देवे... घरवाले भी अगर तकलीफ देवे। तो भी उसको नहीं सुवात है।
जिससे राग करता है वो
अगर तकलीफ देवे तो वो नहीं सुवात है देखो
जीव की परिस्थिति कैसी है। इतना संसार चारों ओर से
तकलीफदाई है असार। तो ज्ञानी पुरुष को मालूम है इस बात का।
एक की निवृत्ति तो बीजाणु परिणाम थहु संभव है। एक की निवृत्ति होगी तो दूसरा
आत्मा लेंगी। संसार में से ही
छुट्टी नहीं होती है तो
आत्मविचारणा कैसे करेगा जीव। तो साधारण जीव को। तो साधारण जीव को
तो इस संसार में तैरना बहुत मुसीबत है।
इसीलिए उसको सबसे पहले एक भाव पे आ जाना चाहिए।
उसको अपनी आत्मा को पूछना चाहिए कि ये थोड़ी सी जिंदगानी है। शरीर के लिए,
परिग्रह के लिए, हर एक के लिए तूने कितने भाव किए? देह ने माटे
हे जीव तूने अनंत भाव बिगाड़ लिए। अनंत जन्म मरण किए।
क्यों देह में बुद्धि थी, मोहित बुद्धि थी।
अब हे जीव संसार से छूटना तो उपाय है। कि देह ने... कि देरने खातर अनंत भव व्यतीत किया
अब संतो कहते हैं कि संत पुरुष कहते हैं कि।
तुम सिर्फ एक भव अपने आत्मा के लिए दे दो।
सिर्फ एक भव इसमें से भी कई जिंदगी तो निकल गई है।
किसी की तो आधी से ज्यादा निकल गई है।
बाकी की जो बची हुई जिंदगी सिर्फ आत्मा के लिए लगाना
है। मुझे सिर्फ आत्मा चाहिए और कुछ नहीं चाहिए संसार के पूरे रंग तंग निकाल दो।
क्या होगा क्या नहीं होगा
निकाल दो। निकाल देने से आपके भाव बंद हो जाएंगे क्रिया बंद नहीं। से आपके
भाव बंद हो जाएंगे क्रिया बंद नहीं होगी
क्रिया तो जैसी होने वाली है
ऐसी ही होगी पहले रोटी बनाने का भाव नहीं आएगा तो फिर रोटी कैसे
बनेगी देखो होता है कि नहीं होता
है होगा ही होगा
क्योंकि वो होने वाला है जड़ में तो होगा तो आप बिना भाव के
activity में शामिल हो जाएंगे इच्छा नहीं है वो शामिल हो जाओगे बिना भाव के
फायदा क्या होगा कि भावों के कारण जो कर्मों का पोटला बनता था
वो नहीं बंधेगा और आप। वो नहीं बंधेगा। और आपको
उस time में रोटी बनाते बनाते भी सत्संग की बात याद आएगी।
सद्गुरु की बात याद आएगी। आत्म कल्याण की दृढ़ता भावना बढ़ेगी।
कार्य लौकिक चल रहे हैं और अंदर में भावना
विचार सब कैसे चल रहे हैं? कब मेरे आत्मा का हित होगा?
कब मेरे आत्मा का दर्शन होगा? कब सत्संग मिलेगा? आज सत्संग में कैसी बात आई थी?
उसका thinking चलता है। कार्य संसार की प्रवृत्ति के चलते हैं। और अंदर में भावना
पूरी... अंदर में भावना पूरी बदल गई। ऐसा हो सकता है।
भावना बिल्कुल धर्म कल्याण करने की, आत्म कल्याण की हो
और क्रिया संसार की प्रवृत्ति की हो, देखने की, सुनने की, चखने की, ये सब हो।
ऐसा बन सकता है।
कि अंदर का change होता है, दूसरों को मालूम पड़े ना भी पड़े,
क्योंकि अंदर की बात है, अंदर में change हुआ है।
तो आत्मार्थी जीव को अंदर में सुविचारणा चलती है, planning चलता है।
जिस बात की हमको important लगती है ना, वो
बात की planning चलती है। किस... किस बात की importance है?
कौन सा कदम कौन सा काम निपटाना है? वो
वो target बनाने के बाद अपने आप विचार उसके अनुसार ही चलेंगे।
जैसे घर में शादी हो तो अभी पूरा planning उसके अनुसार ही चलेगा देखो अपने आप।
नहीं करना है तो भी चलेगा ही चलेगा। क्योंकि
ये तारीख fix हो गई है ये सब तो अब इसके अनुसार सब
आगे की पूरी बातें fixing हो जाएंगी। समय के पहले कपड़े आ जाना, समय के पहले
सब band baaje हो जाना, समय
के पहले सब... सब band-baaje हो जाना
समय के पहले सब। सब booking हो जाना complete।
ताकि end moment में दौड़ा-दौड़ी नहीं हो पंचायत ना हो देखो पूरा।
ये अपने आप आते हैं विचार। क्योंकि हमने target एक fix कर दिया date fix कर दिया है।
ऐसे इसके अंदर एक target fix कर दो। कि मुझे आज का आज ही आत्मकल्याण करना है।
जितना जल्दी होवे आत्मकल्याण करना इसके अलावा अभी कुछ नहीं करना है।
तो इतना fix करते ही पूरे विचार जो है
आपके अंदर में पलट जाएंगे। विचार पलटते ही संसार। विचार पलटते
ही संसार की प्रवृत्ति नहीं रुकेगी।
और किसी का बाधारूप नहीं बनोगे, दुकान भी जाओगे, घर में भी काम संभालोगे। सब होता है।
लेकिन अंदर की स्थिति जो है बदल गई पूरी, भावों की स्थिति। पहले भाव परिवर्तन होता है,
रुचि बदलती है। सबसे पहले उपयोग नहीं आता है आत्मा के अंदर।
सबसे पहले भावों की बदलना होता है कि संसार किसी भी कीमत पे नहीं चाहिए।
मुझे सिर्फ आत्मा ही चाहिए, ऐसा एक अंदर में भावों का बदलाव होता है।
इसके लिए अवलोकन compulsory है। अवलोकन के बिना ये संभव नहीं है।
निरंतर जागृति में रहने की कोशिश करते करते करते करते अंदर के भाव पूरे बदल जाते हैं।
जिसके पूरे पूरे भाव बदल गए हैं सिर्फ आत्मा चाहिए उसको आत्मा मिलता है।
हर एक को आत्मा नहीं मिलता है भले ही ध्यान करें या कुछ भी करें व्रत तप उपवास करें।
हर एक को आत्मा नहीं मिलता है भाव बदलते हैं तो आत्मा का दर्शन हो सकता है।
भाव नहीं बदलते हैं तो आत्मा के दर्शन नहीं होता है
तो ये बात यहाँ कहते हैं। एक नहीं निवृत्ति
तो बीजानु परिणाम थमु संवेष संसार के भावों की निवृत्ति
बिल्कुल stop तो दूसरे की स्थिति उत्पन्न होती है कौन सी आत्मकल्याण की।
लेकिन दोनों साथ में नहीं रहेंगे संसार के
भाव भी और आत्मकल्याण दोनों साथ में नहीं होता है।
अहित हेतु एवं संसार संबंधी प्रसंग।
संसार के जो भी प्रसंग है शादी ब्याह के हो कि और कोई भी हो।
व्यापार धंधे के हो। या कोई बीमारी हो तो hospital में जा... या कोई
बीमारी हो तो hospital में जाना पड़ता हो।
ऐसे कोई भी प्रसंग हो, birthday हो, ऐसा कोई भी प्रसंग।
संसार संबंधी कोई भी प्रसंग है वो कैसे है? अहित हेतु है। अहित हेतु माने क्या?
इससे जीव का अंश मात्र भी भला होने वाला नहीं है। चाहे खुशी के हो,
चाहे दुखी होने के हो, कोई भी प्रसंग संसार के हैं, ये जीव को अहित का कारण बनता है।
अहित हेतु एवं संसार संबंधी प्रसंग, ये हमारे पूर्व कर्मों के उदय के
अनुसार जो जो... ये हमारे पूर्व कर्मों के उदय के
अनुसार जो जो घटनाएं घटती हैं वो। दूसरा हमारा लौकिक भाव।
कि हमको लोगों को जैसा व्यवहार में होता है, लोगों को जैसा पसंद है,
लोग उंगली नहीं उठावे, इस प्रकार से हमको काम करना है।
लोगों में बदनामी ना हो, लोग कोई उंगली नहीं उठावे,
व्यवहार बराबर निभाना है, व्यवहार में कहीं गलती ना हो जावे हमारे से।
हम गलती करेंगे तो अच्छा नहीं लगेगा। ऐसा जो हमारा लौकिक भाव,
संसार संबंधी प्रसंग उदय। संसार संबंधी प्रसंग उदय अनुसार अनुकूल प्रतिकूल। और
इसमें joint होने वाले लोगों को
अच्छा दिखाने के लिए व्यवहार निभाने का जो भाव है वो लौकिक भाव। और ये
तो भाव अब वो लोक चेष्टा।
सिर्फ भाव है ऐसा नहीं फिर लोगों को
बाहर से भी दिखे कि हम आपके जैसे
ही हैं आपके जैसा ही व्यवहार करना चाहते हैं आपसे अलग नहीं हैं ऐसा करके
लोगों को सुहावे ऐसा action reaction प्रवृत्ति। उदय प्रसंग। लौकिक भाव। वे प्रसंग
लौकिक भाव और लौकिक क्रिया सांसारिक क्रिया ज्ञानियों की क्रिया नहीं।
लोकी लोगों को अच्छा लगे ऐसी क्रियाएं मन वचन काया के प्रवर्त्त।
अहित हेतु ये सब क्या है जीव का कल्याण करने वाला नहीं है। अहित करने वाला है बहुत
क्योंकि आत्मज्ञान नहीं हुआ और ऐसे लफड़े में फंसा है तो होने वाला भी नहीं है।
अहित हेतु ऐसा संसार संबंधी प्रसंग लौकिक भाव और लोक चेष्टा। और
लोग कैसे? ये सौनी संभाल जेम बने तेम जति करेने।
क्योंकि एकदम possible नहीं है तो क्या कह दिया?
जितना हो सके दूर रहना, बहुत संभालना, बहुत संभालना ऐसा।
Maximum जहाँ तक अपनी ताक़त हो वहाँ तक avoid करते जाओ, avoid, दूर रखो, दूर रखो सब।
जेम बने तेम ये सौनी संभाल।
नहीं संभालूँगा तो नुकसान हो जाएगा, नहीं संभालूँगा तो ये
लोग क्या बोलेंगे? ऐसा। अच्छा नहीं लगेगा। तो ये। अच्छा नहीं लगेगा।
ये सौनी संभार जेम बने तेम जति करीनी। Avoid करना।
नहीं होता है avoid तो क्या करना?
भाई कोई प्रश्न ऐसे हैं कि भई हम तो अभी शामिल होना ही पड़ता है।
हम उसको छोड़ के भाग नहीं सकते हैं तो क्या करना? दूसरा point अब।
तेने संक्षेपिन। 8 घंटे का
program हो तो उसको कैसा भी
करके 4 घंटे में खत्म कर। 4 घंटे
का हो तो 2 घंटे में। जितना हो सके minimize कर देना है। तेने संक्षेपिन।
आत्महित ने अवकाश अपो घटे छे। इतने अवकाश अपो घटे छे।
संक्षेप करके लौकिक भाव से निवृत्ति ले करके, लौकिक प्रवृत्ति से निवृत्ति ले करके,
चाहे जैसे उदय प्रसंग में हमको अपना आत्मा का हित कैसे होवे, ऐसा planning करना चाहिए।
अगर ऐसा समय नहीं खींच के निकालोगे तो
बहुत परेशानी हो जाएगी। ये 51 number का माताजी का बोल है।
इसमें भी बहुत अच्छी बात कही है। आकाश... आकाश पाताल भले एक था।
तो आकाश पाताल एक होता है तो क्या होता है? करोड़पति रोडपति हो जाता है।
ऐसी परिस्थिति इतना नुकसान होता है। कि जो believe ही नहीं कर सकते।
एकदम अटाकटा आदमी एकदम अचानक cancer घोषित हो जाए 2-3 महीने
दिन का मेहमान है। 2-3 महीने का मेहमान है ऐसा हो जाए आकाश पाताल एक हो जाए।
कि हम believe ही नहीं कर सके अरे अब इतना अच्छे थे
और ऐसे cancer कैसे हो सकता है कभी बीड़ी नहीं पिया सुपारी नहीं खाया वो
नहीं खाया। कैसे हो सकता है?
हटे कटे इंसान को अचानक kidney fail हो जाए लो। ये क्या हो गया? आकाश पाताळ एक।
जो हमने सोचा नहीं है कर्मों का उड़े कब उड़े में आएगा पाप का उड़े
कब दुनिया पलट जाएगी हमको कोई पता नहीं। दुकान में आग लग जाए।
कोई चोरी जबरदस्त हो जाएगी पूरा छिन जावे। जावे और accident हो जाए हाथ पैर टूट जावे।
जीवन भर का अपाहिज हो जावे। देखो
ये क्या हो गया है अनहोनी। देखो ये क्या हो गया है अनहोनी होती है ऐसी घटना
संसार में रोज़ बरोज़ घटती है।
हमारे पे नहीं गुजरी है बाकी लोगों पे तो रोज़।
चालू ही है रोज़ paper में news आता ही है।
उसकी ज़िंदगी पूरी पलट जाती है 1 second के अंदर। दिवाली का वो फटाकड़ा देखने गया।
फटाकड़ा आ गया पूरा जल गया। ऐसा होता है। संसार में ऐसे प्रसंग रोज़ बनते हैं।
कि संसार का असार स्वरूप जो है स्वर्णभंग। सार स्वरूप जो है स्वर्ण भंगुर स्वरूप है।
वो देख करके पढ़ करके सुन करके ज्ञानियों को तो वैराग्य आता है कि
ये संसार में किसका भरोसा रखें कब न जाने कब क्या हो जावे। क्या भरोसा रखें?
आकाश पाताल भले एकता है भले ऐसी स्थिति आवे कि तेरी वस्तु की चले नहीं
एकदम तुम्हारी स्थिति एकदम खराब हो जावे। पर भाई थारा ध्येय ने तू चुपिस ने।
तेरा ध्येय है मनुष्य जन्म सफल करने का आत्मदर्शन करने का
आत्मा की संभालने का। आत्मा की संभाल रखना। उसको तुम चाहे जैसे
प्रसंग में भी पीछे नहीं हटो।
आ गई। सारा प्रयत्न ने छोड़िस नहीं, पहले जो कोशिश है, जागृति है,
सुविचारणा है, आत्महित कैसे होवे उसकी सुविचारणा है, उसको तुम छोड़ना नहीं।
आत्मार्थ ने पोषण मरेते कार्य करू, जिससे हमारी आत्मा की भावना बढ़े,
ऐसे सत्संग, भक्ति आदि
कार्य करते रहना, जागृति में रहते रहना। दूसरा कार्य नहीं
करना। आत्मभावना कमजोर। करना।
आत्मभावना कमजोर पड़े ऐसे संग में, प्रसंग में, कुसंग में,
असत्संग में तुम नहीं रहना, वहाँ छोड़ देना।
दूसरों को बुरा लगेगा तो ऐसा होगा तो वो नहीं देखना, वो साथ छोड़ देना।
जे ध्येय चढ़े ते पूर्ण करजे। जिस ध्येय को तुमने पकड़ा है,
उसको कैसा भी करके तुम पार पड़ना। जरूर तेरे को सिद्धि होगी। तू सफल हो जाएगा।
ये बात यहाँ कही है।
दूसरा भी एक बोल है कि, चाया जैसी कटोकटी में भी। चाहे जैसी कटोकटी में भी तू तेरे
ज्ञान और ध्यान का समय निकाल लेना।
ये अमूल्य मनुष्य जीवन बेकार चले जाता है प्रपंचों में।
उसमें समय मिलता नहीं है आत्मकल्याण के बारे में सोचने को।
लेकिन अगर तुझे मुक्ति चाहिए तो
चाहे जैसी कटोकटी में भी। कि इधर सम इधर को देखे तो वो बिगड़े।
उधर देखे तो ये बिगड़े ऐसी परिस्थिति। कटोकटी किसको बोलते हैं?
कि दोनों को संभालना possible ही नहीं है एक को
तो छोड़ना पड़ता है practically। एक को तो छोड़ना पड़ता है practically भी। क्या करना?
ऐसी कटोकटी में भी तू तेरे ज्ञान ध्यान का समय खींच निकालना, उसको तो तू नहीं छोड़ना।
चाहे कुछ भी हो जाए।
क्योंकि वो तो कुछ भी हो जाए उसमें तो पूर्व कर्म है ना,
उसमें तो तेरी कोई चलने वाली है भी नहीं ऐसे भी तो।
तुम ध्यान रखेगा तो भी तेरा बुरा time आया तो अच्छा time होने
वाला भी नहीं है। तुम चाहे कितना भी ध्यान रख ले।
जब तेरे पाप का उड़े आया तो कुछ नहीं हो सकता है।
इंद्र, नरेंद्र, धिनेंद्र कोई कुछ कर सकता नहीं है।
मंत्र तंत्र औषध कुछ काम नहीं आते हैं, सब हाथ ऊँचे कर देते हैं।
कोई बचाने वाला कोई नहीं है।
कोई हाथ पकड़ने वाला नहीं है क्योंकि बुरा time आया तो
कितना भी गिड़गिड़ा, कितना भी ध्यान कर, कितनी भी प्रार्थना कर,
कितना भी मंत्र तंत्र कर ले
तेरा कोई कार्य होने वाला नहीं है। Better ये है कि अभी इसके
बेकार का जो नहीं हो सके उस कार्य के पीछे जाने के बदले,
जो हमारा कार्य हो सकता है। और लोक चेष्टा।
ते सउनी संभाल जेम बने तेम जति करीने। जो तू न करे तो तेने संक्षेपीने।
आत्महितने अवकाश आपो घटे से। क्योकि संसार में पल पल खतरा है।
ज्ञानी पुरुष भी बहुत ध्यान रख करके कदम कदम पे
देख देख के चल रहे हैं बहुत पुरुषार्थ उनको भी करना पड़ता है।
तुझे आत्मज्ञान नहीं हुआ है
तेरी स्थिति तो बहुत खतरनाक है। तुझे ये सब बहुत ध्यान रख करके कदम उठाना
है। बहुत ध्यान रख कर के कदम उठाना है। कैसा भी करके आत्महित को अवकाश देना है।
अब चलो हम तैयार कर लिए कि हमको आत्महित करना ही है,
इतना सुनने के बाद अंदर में विचार आया।
बात तो बिल्कुल सही है, practically भी दिखती है, संसार में ऐसा ही है।
कब स्थिति बदल जावे, कब क्या हो जाए, कोई पता नहीं, भरोसा नहीं। और अंदर के जो
राग भाव हैं, राग द्वेष के, वो मिटते नहीं हैं, मिटेंगे नहीं तो
मुक्ति कैसे हो अब? और फिर जो
कर्म के पोटले बांध रहे हैं, उसमें दुखी तो आखिर में हम ही होने
वाले हैं। बांध रहे हैं उसमें दुखी तो आखिर में हम ही होने वाले
हैं। हमको ही सब भोगना है जैसे हम भाव करेंगे जैसा
बीज बोएंगे वैसा ही फल आएगा। संसार का बीज बोया है तो संसार बढ़ेगा जन्म मरण
होते जाएंगे। तो फिर हमको संभालना
है सावधान होना है अभी हमको आत्महित
करना है ऐसा अगर हमने तय किया है तो।
तब उपाय की बात करते हैं।
कि अगर ऐसा हमारे अंदर में भावना होती है तो सबसे पहले
क्या कार्य करें। किंतु आत्महित करना है तो सबसे पहले क्या। इंतरा आत्मय करना है तो
सबसे पहले क्या काम करना होगा?
तो कोई भी कार्य करना है तो कार्य करने की जो विधि है वो पहले जानना पड़ता है। क्या?
अगर विधि में गड़बड़ हुई तो भावना होने पर भी कार्य नहीं होगा। भावना तो अच्छी है।
लेकिन कैसे करना कैसे पार पहुँचना?
नैया तो मिल गई लेकिन किनारा ये बाजू है और हम मदबरिया ये बाजू है।
और दरिया के पानी के ऊपर तो road का कोई sign board वगैरह लगे हैं
क्या? chance और board वगैरह लगे हैं क्या
कि A side जाओगे तो किनारा आएगा और A side जाओगे तो
बीच में जाओगे ऐसा तो कुछ symptom नहीं है।
road पे तो आपको मिल जाएंगे arrow mark मिल जाएंगे
कितना कदम चले कितना kilometer चले सब मिल जाता है।
लेकिन दरिया के अंदर गए तो?
और किनारे पे जाना है और गलती से अगर wrong direction हो गया तो क्या होगा?
देखो अब क्या होता है। इसीलिए आत्महित करना है।
आत्महित कैसे करना है वो पहले जान लेना है। कोई भी कदम उठाने के पहले।
Mumbai जाना है तो Mumbai जाने वाली train कौन सी है? 8 10 train platform पे खड़ी है।
सब platform full है हर
platform पे गाड़ी है। कौन सी गाड़ी Mumbai जाती है? कहीं ऐसा
ना हो कि जल्दबाजी में
Madras की train में बैठ गए Delhi की train में बैठ गए।
जानकारी पूरी लेने के बाद उतना time तो आपको देना ही है। इसके बाद आपको कदम उठाना है।
भावना intact है लेकिन भावना को सफल करने के लिए planning जरूरी है,
सब कुछ जानना जरूरी है विधि।
वो विधि कहाँ मिलती है? वो काम पहले करना है। तो देखो क्या कहते हैं।
आत्महित माते सत्संग जेहुँ बड़वान बीजू निमित्त कोई जणातु नते।
देखो अब आखिर बात आई घूम फिर के सत्संग।
तो अगर आपको आत्मकल्याण करना है, मुक्ति
पाना है तो। आपके पास कोई alternative... आपके पास कोई alternative नहीं है।
ऐसे बहुत से दर्शन, पूजा, भक्ति,
त्याग, वैराग्य ऐसे बहुत से हैं लेकिन सबसे बलवान कौन? सबसे बलवान निमित्त,
उपादान नहीं, उपादान तो तू स्वयं। लेकिन जहाँ guidance मिलता है, perfect,
भगवान के दर्शन करने में guidance नहीं मिलता है।
पूजा करने में नहीं मिलता है, शास्त्र पढ़ने में भी हम
हो सकता है अर्थ का अनर्थ कर देवे।
समझने में गलती करें। 45 number की गाथा में आता है कि
राग द्वेष के भाव जीव नहीं करता है। 46 number की गाथा में आता है कि राग द्वेष के
भाव जीव ही करता है, अब क्या बोलोगे बताइए, क्या अर्थ करोगे?
शास्त्र पढ़ने में भी हम ये गलती कर सकते हैं कि
खाली यहाँ ऐसा कहा यहाँ ऐसा कहा, किसकी बात मानना? कौन
सी बात मानना, वही author है। एक ही गाथा का फर्क है 45 46, समय सार की। इतनी opposite
बात। हम समझ नहीं पाते हैं, आज।
हम समझ नहीं पाते हैं, आशाएं नहीं समझ पाते हैं। क्या करें? तो कोई भी प्रवृत्ति में
हमको जगाने के लिए, हमारा आत्महित में
जल्दी से progress होवे, इसके लिए सबसे बलवान निमित्त कौन सा?
सत्संग।
आत्महित माते सत्संग जेहुं
बड़वान बीजू निमित्त कोई पान जणातुं नथी। आप नग्न दिगंबर हो जाओ,
मुनि बन जाओ, जंगल में रह जाओ, वो निमित्त नहीं है।
ये तो आपने सीधा
जानकारी लिए बिना सीधा action शुरू कर दिया है। Action शुरू कर दिया है। विधि
तो मालूम नहीं है कि कैसे
करना और सीधा कार्य शुरू कर दिया है।
उसने उपवास किया मैं भी उपवास करूँ मेरे को भी शायद मिल जाएगा।
Vishvadeva भगवान ने वर्सी तप किया था और मोक्ष में गए।
हम भी शुरू करो हर साल वर्सी तप करो एक नहीं 10 करो। क्या हुआ?
मोक्ष मोक्ष तो बहुत दूर की बात है।
अंश मात्र भी शरीर के प्रति
संयोगों के प्रति मोह कम नहीं हुआ है राग द्वेष कम नहीं हुआ है।
कितने साल से वर्सी तप
करते हो? पिछले 10 साल से लगातार वर्सी तप। पिछले 10 साल से लगातार
वर्ष तक कर रहा हूँ। वो
कितना कम हुआ राग द्वेष कितना कम हुआ?
क्योंकि विधि नहीं है।
विधि पहले जानना है और इसके लिए कुछ भी कार्य करने से पहले कदम उठाने से पहले
सत्संग में आना है। चलो सत्संग करना चालू कर दिए। सत्संग आज से शुरू।
ऐसा करके सत्संग में आना शुरू कर दिए। लेकिन वहाँ भी एक problem है।
छता ते सत्संग पण वो सत्संग भी। ते सत्संग पण वो सत्संग भी फायदा
नहीं होता है सत्संग में
जाने के बाद भी। आत्महित के लिए
सत्संग करना है और सत्संग किया तो भी
फायदा नहीं हुआ ऐसा भी बनता है। क्या कारण? ते
सत्संग पण जे जीव लौकिक भाव ती अवकाश देतो नथी तेने प्राय निष्फळ जाय छे।
आत्मकल्याण भी करना है। संसार के
जो हमारे जो उदय प्रसंग है उसको भी संभाल रखना है। घर में भी
ध्यान देना है धंधे में भी ध्यान देना है। करना है धंधे में भी ध्यान देना है
व्यवहार में भी बराबर चलना है और आत्मकल्याण भी करना है
सब हो सकता है 24 घंटा है हमारे पास
सुबह का 1 घंटा शाम का 1 घंटा सत्संग के लिए रख लो 2 घंटा 8-10 घंटे दुकान के लिए रख
लो 2-4 घंटा शरीर के लिए रख लो
सब होता है ना नहीं होता
है क्या थोड़ा इधर ध्यान दे थोड़ा इधर
bowling भी करना आता है fielding करना भी आता है catch पकड़ना भी आता है
और batting करना भी आता
है और wicket keeping भी आता है सब। भी आता है और
wicket keeping भी आता है सब आता है क्या होगा कैसे होगा ये कार्य
होने का संभव ही नहीं है ऐसा नहीं हो सकता है लौकिक भावना
बिल्कुल खत्म हुई तो सत्संग एकदम फलवान हो जाएगा
इतना ज्यादा सत्संग करने की जरूरत नहीं पड़ती है
सत्संग करते जाएं करते जाएं करते जाएं result अभी तक नहीं निकला है जरूर
हमारे में कमी रह गई क्या कमी रह गई हम सत्संग तो बहुत किया।
सही समझा भी, बुद्धि में बैठ भी गया, लेकिन हमने
अभी तक लौकिक भाव को नहीं छोड़ा है। यही वजह
है कि हमको 6 महीना क्या, 6 साल तक भी सत्संग करते हुए भी फायदा नहीं हो रहा
है। 6 जन्मों में भी नहीं होगा। क्यों नहीं होगा?
लौकिक भाव को नहीं छोड़ा, अभी भी आग्रह कितने
पड़े हैं। ऐसा नहीं करना है, ऐसा करना है।
फिर हमारे जो action reaction, ये खाना है, ये नहीं
खाना है। Reaction reaction ये खाना है ये नहीं खाना है।
यहाँ जाना है यहाँ नहीं जाना है।
यहाँ अच्छा लगता है यहाँ अच्छा नहीं लगता है कितने अंदर में प्रपंच पड़े हैं।
हम free नहीं हैं। हमने surrender नहीं किया है वातावरण के
साथ। समझौता नहीं किया उदय के साथ।
उदय आता है तो घबराकर करके fight करने लग जाते हैं अनाप-शनाप कुछ भी जो
भी उपाय आता है कर लेते हैं। सर दुखा तो सर फौरन anesthesia ले लेते हैं
doctor के पास दौड़े जाते हैं।
तब आत्मा याद नहीं आता है आता है याद? कि सर तो ये
दुखा है तो आत्मा को तो ज्ञान होता है।
भले हम उपाय करो लेकिन साथ में ये भाव चलता है कि मैं शरीर से भिन्न
हूँ। वो तो उस time में याद ही नहीं आता इतना दर्द था। कौन भागे ये किया वो किया।
उस time में आत्मा याद नहीं आता doctor आ जाता है। ये लौकिक भाव।
लौकिक भाव भी कहीं गए तो अपना taste का खाना नहीं मिला। परेशान।
ये तो चाहिए ही चाहिए था दाल तो ठंडी नहीं चलेगी गरम ही चाहिए।
मिर्ची कम है नहीं चलेगा मिर्ची चाहिए ये सब कितना क्या क्या हो
गया है ये। क्या क्या हो गया है? आत्मकल्याण के करने वाले के एसे लक्षण तो
नहीं होते है. ए करना है,
ए नहीं करना है, एसा होना है,
एसा नहीं होते है. सारे लौकिक भाव है. तो
फिर एसे लौकिक भाव भी है, हम सत्संग भी करते जावे
और... वी कैसे सफळ होगा? नहीं होगा. सफळ होने का कोई chance नहीं होता है. कितना भी
करे नहीं होता है. सत्संग सिवाय आत्महित माटे बीजुं कोई बढवानुं निमित्त नथी. छता ते
सत्संग पर जे जीव लौकिक भावथी
अवकाश देतो नथी... होती अवकाश देतो नथी. तेने प्राय निष्फळता छे. इसको सफल नहीं होता
है सत्संग बेकार हो जाता
है. इसले सत्संग करने वाले को सबसे
पहेले क्यां बताया गया? के भैया तुं अपने भावो का अवलोकन कर. तु कहा
खडा है तुजे लोक आत्मा
की कल्याण करने की भावना है के
संसार को बढाने की भावना है? तुजे क्यां
है अंदर में क्यां चल रहा है? उसका देखना चालु कर दे. देखेगा तो लौकिक भाव खतम होगा
नहीं देखेगा. एसा ही सत्संग में
आ जायेगा जाग... ऐसे ही सत्संग में आ
जाएगा, जागृति में नहीं रहेगा तो लौकिक भाव बढ़ जाएंगे।
कुछ सत्संग सफल होने वाला नहीं है।
अवलोकन करेगा तो जागृति आएगी तो अपना अच्छा बुरा वो पहचानेगा। दोष के प्रति अब सहज में
दुर्लक्ष होगा। उपेक्षा हो जाएगा, दर्द होगा। अपने आप आत्मक गुण का विकसित होता है,
सत्संग सफल होता है। जितना दोष कम होता है वहां, उतना गुण प्रकट होता है और वो गुण
सत्संग को सफल करने में फायदा होता है।
सत्संग निमित्त है। कार्य अपने गुणों... सीमित है। कार्य अपने गुणों से होने वाला है।
गुणों की वृद्धि होगी, दोषों की कमी होगी, तो हम आगे बढ़ेंगे।
नहीं तो हम आगे नहीं बढ़ेंगे। आकी का
जो पोषण है आधा फल ले लेंगे। सुख धाम अनंत
सुसंत जाही।
दिन रात्रि
रहे
तद ध्यान।
तद ध्यान मही। पर शांति
अनंत सुधा मय जी।
प्रणमु पद ते वरते
जयते।
वरते जयते प्रणमु
पदते वरते जयते।